es gibt sie tatsächlich superhelden
allerdings sind ihre superkräfte im
gehirn verborgen sie können dinge zu
denen so kein anderer mensch fähig ist
und sehr oft beginnt es mit einem
schlimmen unfall jetzt in kingston
science and fiction
heute eine folge die vielleicht mehr
fragen aufwirft als sie beantworten kann
allerdings beschäftigt sie sich mit
einem thema das wirklich mind blowing
ist auf deutsch der hammer können wir
vielleicht alle genies werden
es gibt tatsächlich forscher die daran
arbeiten unsere denkt fähigkeiten zu
steigern und das nicht etwa mit lernen
üben oder trainieren
es soll einfach so gehen per knopfdruck
das ist wirklich ein bisschen strange
aber es ist schon zigmal passiert es
sind sogenannte single begabte menschen
die auf einem gebiet die fähigkeiten
eines genies haben und oft haben sie
diese fähigkeiten einem unfall zu
verdanken von einem auf den anderen tag
waren sie eben auf knopfdruck ein
beispiel kennen viele es ist harald
lesch moderator von alpha centauri und
eine ausnahme begabung im bereich astro
und plasmaphysik das war nicht immer so
bis zur oberstufe vornehmlich
durchschnitt wenn ich sogar
durchschnittlicher durchschnitt der
benötigte förderunterricht und dann
hatte er einen fahrradunfall
schädelbasisbruch und von jetzt auf
gleich war er mathematisch hochbegabt er
studierte physik und philosophie und ist
heute professor für plasma astrophysik
an der münchner universität jason patric
ist ein weiteres beispiel für eine
solche verwandlung bevor er ein
mathegenie wurde lebt werden den tag
hinein job denn ein möbelhaus und
verdiente so gerade so viel geld um ohne
ende party machen zu können
und genau dabei passierte das unglück
vor einer karaoke-bar überfielen zwei
männer und prügelten auf ihn ein
die folge neben einer nieren verletzung
eine schwere gehirnerschütterung
von da an sah er die welt mit anderen
augen jedem blatt in fließendem wasser
einer hand überall erkennt er
geometrische strukturen die zahl pi ist
für ihn kein rätsel und einsteins
relativitätstheorie versteht er intuitiv
stadt partys zu machen
lebt er jetzt zurück gezogen und hat nur
wenig kontakt zu anderen
etwas das er mit autisten gemeinsam hat
auch unter ihnen gibt es solche songs
mit unglaublichen fähigkeiten nur in
einem bestimmten bereich zum beispiel
gold einer der größten pianisten aller
zeiten er war ein autist oder metzger
wahrscheinlicher ist und eben out ist
das klavierspielen hat er sich über
nacht mit sechs jahren selbst
beigebracht heute gilt er als mozart des
jazz es ist verblüffend
woher schöpfen diese menschen ihr wissen
ihr talent ihre fähigkeiten pianist
werden in einer nacht mathegenie durch
eine gehirnerschütterung was passiert da
in unserem gehirn gibt es ein universal
wissen dass wir seite geburt in uns
tragen hat es jeder mensch und wir
müssen es nur aktivieren
tatsächlich gibt es wissenschaftler die
solche thesen vertreten
noam chomsky zb vertritt die these dass
es eine universelle grammatik gibt die
bereits in einem bestimmten bereich
unseres gehirns abgespeichert ist
verehrt von den eltern
untermauert wird diese these von songs
die sprachen in einer woche lernen
können das könnte natürlich auch für
musik und mathematik gelten
es ist schon verrückt aber meine
gespräche mit musikern bestätigen dass
immer wenn es um den moment der
entstehung eines songs ging beschrieben
sie es als einen göttlichen moment eine
inspiration die von außen kommen das
würde bedeuten dass schon unglaublich
viele unseren vorinstalliert ist und es
nur noch zu tage befördert werden muss
jeder könnte dann mathegenie musiker
oder maler werden
professor bruce müller arbeitet mit
demenzkranken die auch plötzlich im
alter besondere begabungen entwickelten
er untersuchte sie und songs im
computertomographen und stellte
verblüffende parallelen fest ein
bestimmte hirnbereiche in der linken
hirnhälfte war kaum noch aktiv und
andere bereiche wurden dadurch stärker
beansprucht hier könnte der schlüssel
für das phänomen liegen und auch die
möglichkeit bei jedem menschen solche
fähigkeiten zu tage befördern
der australische professor allan snyder
versucht das mit einer denkt kappe die
einen bestimmten hirn
reich lahmlegt und andere bereiche
stimuliert dreimal mehr probanden
konnten beim test mit dieser kappe so
eine schwierige matheaufgabe lösen
möglich machten das kleine stromstöße
noch sind diese forschung am anfang aber
auch in anderen bereichen gibt es
studien die das für möglichkeiten an der
ruhr universität bochum wurde mit der
magnet stimulation des gehirns eine
verbesserung des tastsinns erreicht wow
da hat das gehirn etwas gelernt durch
stimulation mit einem magnetfeld
ich weiß das ist jetzt ein bisschen grün
aber das könnte wirklich bedeuten dass
wir unglaublich viel wissen und
fähigkeiten bereits in unserem gehirn
gespeichert haben und es mit einer
gezielten beeinflussung des gehirns zu
tage gefördert wird das wäre wirklich
was soll ich sagen
sensationell sensationell ist übrigens
auch dieses video dunkle materie
gefunden
ein nasa satellit hinweise auf eines der
größten rätsel des universums gefunden
hier klicken dafür links natürlich auch
wie immer in der video beschreibung wie
auch der topix um immer aktuell
informiert wenn ihr hier drauf klickt
über ein abo freue ich mich galaktischen
kostelics und was meint ihr können wir
alle genies werden was ist eure meinung
in die kommentare und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran